Wow oh my god oh my god holy shit
gods of Egypt what have you done I just
got back from seeing gods of Egypt and I
am floored I let me try to compress this
enthusiasm down and be just a little bit
professional gods of Egypt was directed
by Alex Proyas the filmmaker behind the
crow Dark City I Robot and knowing it
tells the story of God's living amongst
men in Egypt one of them is about to
obtain his role and be crowned king when
Gerard Butler shows up and says no that
kingship is mine I want that a war
breaks out and all of a sudden a God has
to team up with a mortal to try to win
back the heart of Egypt guys I really
don't know what to say I really don't
gods of Egypt blew me away I am
absolutely positive that this is the
best worst movie I have seen in years
it's the type of movie that insists it's
good by being very loud and boisterous
at almost all times this movie is so
convinced of how entertaining it is that
it will not let up for even a split
second that's how awful it is it
reminded me of joel schumacher's version
of batman just so huge and
larger-than-life and absolutely
convinced that it was going to make you
believe that it's good but it's not
nearly every scene in this movie
entertained me but not in the way the
filmmakers wanted to I laughed my ass
off throughout the majority of gods of
Egypt this movie is insanely hilarious I
found it incredibly entertaining but in
all of the ways the filmmakers did not
want me to there are so many horrific ly
terrible moments throughout this movie
that had me in stitches if I had this
movie at my disposal like on blu-ray
right now I'd be doing a 20-minute
hilarious 'ti of it no doubt what really
caught me off guard was how much awkward
humor is in this movie it's really
trying to be funny
this movie actually really is trying
hard
to make you laugh and not in the way
that I laughed it's actually trying to
be a humorous movie and that humor fails
at every turn
the action is gigantically bloated it
appears as if every fight scene happened
in a green screen room I mean it's even
worse than the prequels in regards to
its use of CGI this film feels so
horrendously artificial there is barely
a shot in this movie that I believed but
I'm telling you though it was
entertaining if you go into it with the
right mindset this is absolutely a
Batman and Robin for me this is
absolutely a Mortal Kombat annihilation
this is just a gigantic terrible video
game movie disaster even though it's not
even based off a video game there are so
many moments that just don't work in
this film it's Direction is so poor and
I don't necessarily mean the visuals I
mean yes the CG is in-your-face
and some of it is okay and some of it is
terrible and something is not that bad
to be honest what I mean is the
harnessing of tone the the idea of
pacing and making scenes feel as if they
flow naturally making dialogue feel as
if it's coming off of the actors tongues
in the right ways making it all feel
natural and seamless that type of
direction is non-existent in this movie
this movie is a gigantic mess everything
failed this movie is incredible
aye aye sir I really don't know what to
say as I was watching the movie I was
like is this gonna be amazing and then I
realized just what type of amazing it
would be with Gerard Butler's first
fight scene the 360 spinning camera that
never seems to end during every fight
scene in this film it just blew me away
this movie floored me guys it's so bad I
mean it's really terrible it's kind of
awful in every way I can't give this
movie a good grade just because I
laughed at it because I wasn't supposed
to be laughing but I paid money to see
this movie I'm sitting there in the
theater going you know what I'm gonna
have the best of this and my god I
laughed my ass off I'm gonna give gods
of Egypt a big fat fucking F
on a serious note though there are no
Egyptian actors in this film really you
couldn't have at least hired one I mean
he's just as like a courtesy nope we get
draw butler with his orange face guys
don't see gods of Egypt in theaters wait
for it to come out on blu-ray and DVD
rent it get a lot of friends together
and laugh your asses off just like I did
look forward to Sunday guys because
speaking of hilarious ''tis I'm going to
have one and that is going to be for
Supergirl the 1984 films starting in my
series of DC Comics related
entertainment leading up to Batman V
Superman thank you guys so much as
always for watching and if you like this
you can click right here and get stuck
mine eyes